To determine if these statements are true
or false, it's somewhat easier to look at
the diagram we previously discussed. So,
if we look at the first statement, the
integers are a subset of the whole
numbers. We can see that this would be
false because the integers is a larger set
than the set of whole numbers. The whole
numbers are a subset of the integers,
that's true, as is the next statement, the
natural numbers are a subset of the
integers. However, the whole numbers are
not a subset of the natural numbers. You
can see the natural numbers are actually a
subset of the whole numbers, which makes
the last statement true as well. However,
if we look at the statement, the integers
are a subset of the natural numbers, this
is also false. Because as you can see, the
natural numbers are a subset of the
integers. Overall, it's easiest to
determine if a set is a subset of another
set by looking at the circles. If the
circle is entirely contained within
another circle, it is a subset of the set.